il fait ce qu'on lui dit assez
rapidement mais il n'y a aucune
intelligence
alors il nous faut il ne pourra jamais
remplacer complètement l'homme de toute
façon donc vous vous n'êtes pas encore
pour une usine à robot l'établissement
ne paye pas de mine vous attendez à un
décor de science-fiction et vous voilà
devant un entrepôt décrépide la banlieue
de New York et pourtant
[Applaudissements]
je voudrais voir Monsieur Reichelt
français je vais traduire pour lui
easy
je ne pense pas après 10 ans de
recherche et de travaux pour le réaliser
que claytou souhaite une plaisanterie
[Musique]
pour fonctionner dans une maison typique
de 250 mots et je pourrais comprendre
que
ce langage
chaque robot il paraît-il programmé pour
avoir son propre caractère bon dans
l'ensemble mais il était intéressant de
voir comment créer tout allait réagir à
la provocation
[Applaudissements]
je travaille déjà comme un chien ici si
je vais aller travailler pour vous il
faudra être un peu plus organisé vous
savez
[Applaudissements]
est-ce que tu
t'amuses
ce qui est très important tout à fait
fondamental nécessaire c'est de bien
comprendre à quoi ces outils peuvent
servir quelle est la position de l'homme
par rapport à cet outil dans quelle
mesure l'homme commande à cet outil et
comment ces appareils vont répondre et
ceci nous concerne personnellement cette
familiarité elle va être acquise
maintenant que les enfants vont jouer
avec des outils informatiques très
jeunes avec des petites calculatrices et
il y a des clubs qui
se font actuellement et qui permettent
d'expérimenter les microprocesseurs
c'est à dire les cellules élémentaires
mais déjà très intelligentes des
systèmes de calculateurs actuels je
crois que au bout d'un certain temps on
s'habituera assez de cela à la manière
dont on sert du téléphone
les gens au départ savent pas du tout ce
qu'ils veulent ça c'est clair puis là il
voyait un peu le vental des différents
matériels il s'intéresse ça démystifie
un peu informatique
quel est votre formation s'il vous plaît
secondaire
mathématiques et qu'est-ce que vous
faites vous
êtes programmé en Alice et là vous
trouvez donc un micro-tal et qu'est-ce
que vous faites ici en faisant des
programmes plus intéressants et plus
distrayant que dans la gestion
un grand pouvoir d'évolution finalement
ceux qui sont moteurs de ce truc là
parce que les adultes voient des gosses
jouer dessus ils disent pas moi c'est
pas normal maintenant on fait tout
circuit intégré l'appareil photo les
télés les ordinateurs le microprocesseur
lui-même il y a quelques années c'était
franchement un progrès énorme parce que
il contenait toute la capacité de calcul
une ou deux armoires remplies de de mes
compresseurs et comme
la plus sceptique plus ça change d'aller
vite parce que comme le courant
électrique va aussi vite que la lumière
là le micro-presseur va très très vite
puisque c'est une pastille de 5 mm sur 5
donc silicium bourré de 20000
transistors et il y a des choses que
bien sûr l'ordinateur ne peut pas faire
parce que l'ordinateur n'a pas n'a pas
l'intelligence
il a il fait ce qu'on lui dit assez
rapidement mais il n'y a aucune
intelligence
alors il nous faut il ne pourra jamais
remplacer complètement l'homme de toute
façon donc vous vous n'êtes pas inquiet
non pas encore
dans tous les gestes du quotidien dans
toutes les étapes du quotidien ça
commence déjà à se développer maintenant
dans les machines à laver on a aussi
et ça c'est bien votre famille
oui
toujours l'aspect évidemment grand
public c'est on peut pas y échapper ça
permet d'avoir le côté jeu qui est
intéressant pour justement
sensibilisation et le côté professionnel
mais il y a toujours au départ un fond
de recherche qui est pour l'utilité
publique des choses comme ça
[Musique]
moi je suis
informaticien dans la mesure où
j'enseigne informatique à l'université
Dijon et oui je viens découvrir et puis
animé des clubs qui fonctionnent aussi
chez nous et faire un échange avec
Microtel Paris et qu'est-ce qui vous
intéresse surtout alors d'informatique
vous avez un petit hobby vous me dit
particulier
dans des expositions il a eu 8 en 2 ans
et ils ont fait l'année dernière et une
boutique de création artistique ouverte
au grand public qui se tenait dans les
rues d'Albi et alors le mariage peut se
faire entre l'informatique et là a
priori nous ça nous paraît plutôt froid
plutôt inesthétique et bien le mariage
s'est bien fait entre le pinceau et
l'artiste l'ordinateur est un outil ça
peut être un outil aussi bien pour le
créateur artistique pour quelqu'un qui
fait de la gestion c'est un petit peu
nouveau peut-être mais ça marche
est un petit aspect il y a l'aspect
électronique en est un autre qui fait
marcher le premier puis à la spé si bien
éthique qui va être l'an 2000 ça c'est
certain la miniatorisation de ces
composants là en maintenant on fait des
ordinateurs dans les volumes de plus en
plus réduits et ça c'est la tendance
actuelle on cherche à minaturiser pour
aborder l'âge de Miss c'est à dire la
cybernétique les robots en bref qu'on
soyons clairs donc ça les gens ils sont
ils sont très sensibles c'est évident
donc ils essayent un peu ici de
s'informer mais en rêvant au robot une
petite machine donc l'objectif dans le
grand public c'est d'une part de
sensibiliser pour les habituer un peu à
ce nouveau être que va être le robot
donc on essaye ici d'une part de les
habituer à la mini informatique ensuite
de passer l'électronique pour compléter
leur première bagages et pour déboucher
à ce qu'on évoque ici c'est à dire la
cybernétique pour arriver à fabriquer
des robots leur montrer l'histoire d'un
grand public etc c'est quoi
alors le robot c'est réaliser un
automate miniaturisé qui réalise des
tâches courantes genre domestiques ou
applicable dans l'industrie pour des
chaînes de transferts ou des choses même
genre et ça ce serait pour quand votre
avis
on a déjà construit des maquettes de
robots il y a à peu près 5-6 ans je
pense que dans une dizaine d'années ou
peut-être même une vingtaine on pourra
voir des robots se balader dans les
cuisines ça pratiquement évident
vous voulez des surprises en voilà après
la voiture fabriquée par les robots
pourquoi pas la voiture qui se conduit
toute seule ou presque une seule main
suffit
cette Renault 30 équipée dans le
laboratoire du professeur rabbichon à
Montpellier et la première du genre plus
besoin de volant celui qui est à droite
ne sert qu'à l'apprentissage avec le
moniteur tout est dans la poignée dites
à effort intégré niveau 1 ni une
simple pression de la main millimétrée
tout doucement à gauche à droite pour
tourner un ordinateur entre les deux
sièges arrières transforme les
impulsions des codes et transmets les
ordres aux éléments mécaniques qui
remplacent les gestes habituels freinées
et accélérées par exemple
nous voilà donc dans un monde envoi de
robotisation remplacée soulagée assisté
bien sûr mais frustré vous n'êtes pas
convaincu vous attendez encore le robot
qui vous ferait un clin d'oeil accompli
c'est quoi
le robot qu'on a d'abord
représenté de formes humaine c'est un
peu l'esclave de l'antiquité que on
essaye de déshumaniser c'est une machine
esclave alors en fait dans l'industrie
on a d'abord fait des machines tout
court qui se substituent au gestes
humains et puis des machines
automatiques et puis ce qu'on appelle
des robots dans l'industrie qui sont des
manipulateurs avec tous les mouvements
de la main toutes les possibilités de la
main qu'un homme a en fait
entraîné auquel l'homme a appris son
geste et puis qui le répète d'une façon
définitive et automatique et c'est un
robot
un peu idiot c'est un robot qui se
contente de répéter toujours la même
chose dans le robot de demain l'évolue
vers l'auto-adaptativité au lieu d'un
robot qui ne peut faire qu'une chose
bien définie dans les conditions très
strictes le robot va s'adapter à un
minimum d'imprévus et ce minimum va
devenir un maximum et alors le robot
deviendra de plus en plus autonome bien
entendu on n'a pas encore un robot
auquel on va dire on va chercher mais
pantoufles qui vous répond elles sont
pas rangées au bon endroit
pas mal en effet pour un robot que
dites-vous maintenant de ce robot
d'intérieur c'est à Rock l'enfant de
Benjamin scora un bricoleur de Chicago
mais ne vous trompez pas à Rock n'a pas
d'autonomie tout au plus c'est un gadget
radioguidé il se prépare dans les
laboratoires du futur des robots
outrement plus fascinants puisque déjà
il voit prennent des décisions bientôt
ils auront des sensations tactiles
pouvoir donner un ordre à un robot
dialogué avec lui sans fil sans appareil
lui faire comprendre exactement ce que
l'on désire afin qu'il exécute est-ce
possible ailleurs qu'au cinéma
en regardant à rock que vous risquez
bien en être convaincu
et bien ne soyez pas victime à Rock ne
s'entretient avec sa maîtresse qu'avec
un talkie-walkie son maître bien caché
lui prête sa voix tout simplement
si vous voulez connaître un robot qui
dialogue avec son maître directement
alors venez donc voir les chercheurs de
la faculté d'Orsay
monsieur Angelo Sorio donnait à un robot
une voix humaine lui apprendre à
reconnaître directement la voix de son
maître est-ce que c'est important pour
nous c'est très sympa nous misons nos
recherches sur l'utilisation de la
communication parlée en robotique vous
ne devez voir hilare à Toulouse nous
nous occupons un robotique de tout ce
qui concerne la communication en général
la communication parler en particulier
pourquoi pour nous la communication
parlait est importante nous passons
d'abord que c'est un moyen très naturel
le plus naturel de tous et communiquer
avec une machine puisqu’un machine et
ensuite il dispose de toute la
versatilité que vous voudriez aussi bien
entrer qu'un sorti aussi bien pour faire
comprendre pour reconnaître d'accord
c'est c'est le but de nos recherches
répéter
la phrase que le système vient de
synthétiser au fait il y a un point très
important sur toute cette synthèse de
France et ce sont des morceaux de parole
qui n'ont jamais été enregistrées
l'ordinateur génère une suite de son à
partir des morceaux des paroles pris
dans sa mémoire il aimait côte à côte il
génère des phrases mais on fait de la
voie est un peu bizarre parce que jamais
personne ne l'enregistré c'est une voix
qui n'est pas humaine d'autre part le
système vient de nous donner un choix et
on peut introduire actuellement et soit
des obstacles les services réalisés les
temps de l'univers du robot l'univers du
robot peut être par exemple c'est pas le
domaine d'évolution de d'un chariot ou
d'un robot style hilar que vous avez vu
à Toulouse qui se déplace dans ce hangar
ou peu importe
il va réussir bébé sera rentré
voilà
la maison
les contours par la droite
le robot complet doué de la vision de
l'audition du langage l'esclave qui se
met seul et dialogue directement avec
son maître pensez-vous que c'est
possible dès à présent à mon avis c'est
possible il faut réaliser un travail de
synthèse entre les différents
laboratoires qui s'occupent chacun de
d'une partie de ce robots qu'on va sans
aucun doute réaliser vous savez il est
là bon bah ici on fait des recherches
sur la communication parler mais sans
aucun doute c'est possible néanmoins il
faut pas penser que ces robots aura une
apparence anthropomorphique on essaye
pas de faire une copie de l'homme pas du
tout on essaie d'extraire certains
nombre de fonctions très subtiles
d'augmenter peut-être certains
performances si le force capacité de
déplacement vitesse etc pour ensuite
faire des sous-titres qui est des
performances vraiment ponctuelles qui
soient utilisables pour une fonction
pour une autre
ce robot du Commissariat à l'énergie
atomique ne prendra jamais votre valise
il est vous à des tâches plus
dangereuses à aller dans des lieux où
l'homme ne peut pas s'aventurer
vous êtes peut-être déçu ces robots
n'excitent pas l'imagination ils en
manque même seul l'homme finalement peut
les rendre dangereux
mais cela ne m'étonnerait pas carotte
soit de tous les robots celui que vous
préférez il est un parfait truqué
vantard dépendant en un mot tellement
humain
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]